what was the biggest bet you ever made
oh god almighty
um i don't know i i one time
i mean the most i lost in one night were
because three times i've lost everything
that i've ever had how do you do that i
mean not not immorally but i mean like
how do you physically do it well yeah i
mean like you know you you like you make
one more like what is the process of
that
what's the evolution
it's funny because it's a
the only time i went to a psychiatrist
he said like i was like because it was
for gambling yeah how the [ __ ] do i get
out of this and he's like oh you gamble
to avoid
uh life you know and i'm like but my my
thing was well isn't that why you do
everything in life used to [ __ ] avoid
this you know what i mean like too
painful yeah
so i said uh but
uh it's painful to think about but uh
um because because now it would be nice
to have the money
but um
you just lose it by uh
by it's just like any escape i guess
because i was never a drug or alcohol
guy but like when i watch a game and i
have a bunch of money on it then i can
understand what's going on nothing's
ambivalent or anything about it you know
and there's stakes there's stakes you
know exactly the rules yeah you're
completely involved and you're
completely escaped from your life yeah
of the the real yeah the real um
the real fear you know i'd rather fear
losing money in a football game
than uh ruminate all
[ __ ] night about uh about my upcoming
uh
show illness yeah
yeah no not my show
my biggest problem is ruminating about
death if i could get over that somehow
you do that regularly i try to i read
[ __ ] books about it and [ __ ]
have you read that becker book denial of
death oh yeah yeah it's my favorite book
in the world oh it is yeah i have both i
have all his books
i'm getting his newsletter and he's dead
the becker foundation it's helped me a
little bit yeah well well that's uh the
whole idea of that is the the
transferencing that you know you to feel
part of something bigger than yourself
to define your life and you can do with
that what you want i mean it's better if
it's god than gambling i think in some
god is the best yeah so i mean i i i i
that's what i'm trying to get to is god
well let's go let's get let's get let's
get to god piecemeal so like you still
haven't walked me through losing
everything
well um how you do it yeah because like
i mean because like you know you've got
a house you you had a lot of money saved
up and and and then like so you make one
bet and then you realize you're you're
about to use everything do you make
phone calls to people saying like i just
need a little more i mean well you know
you kind of at the end of it you know
it's happening it's i guess it's like
i've never had substance abuse problems
but i guess it's like people that
know they're going to hit bottom you
know and kind of want it yeah because it
does get it it's exhausting yeah to be
obsessed with something right so um you
are i guess um
trying to do it trying to finish it off
right finally well if you're if you have
450 000 in the bank yeah whatever the
[ __ ] it was and then you lose 400
thousand you're [ __ ] it i don't want to
[ __ ] have 50 000
to remind me that i don't want money to
remind me that i have more money
so that's how you do it so that's how
you know yeah and you did that three
times three times in my life yeah and
and how long have you been off it
um
we've been off at like probably five
years or so yeah and you're trying to
get to some spirituality in your life
i'm trying to
because all i uh the only real joy i get
uh other than i love watching comedy but
uh anything deeper than that is i read a
lot of literature and stuff i'm not
i'm not educated like i never had any
schooling
and i don't read non-fiction much but i
read lots of literature
and um like who uh telstra oh yeah but
the um
faith keeps coming up like these
[ __ ] are smart yeah i mean you
know like i was always like you know uh
pryor's this [ __ ] most deep profound
guy i haven't [ __ ] heard from my
limited perspective now all of a sudden
i'm reading books i'm like holy [ __ ]
this guy knows everything like i was
reading tolstoy i was like [ __ ] one
word one sentence this guy
and so but then i was like why are all
these guys
it all comes down to faith you know it
seems to every [ __ ] great novel i
read
it seems like faith is the the only um
um salvation yeah so
but i don't know how to get it yeah
yeah like i don't know how to just
suddenly believe surrender yeah i don't
know how to do that i'm not i'm too i
don't know i'm too uh
stupid or proud or pretend i'm smart or
whatever or afraid probably afraid yeah
just yeah it's a surrender it's hard
it's it's like this equation that your
brain has to do where you realize that
you have very little control over
anything that that moment where you
realize like you know just about all of
it
is out of my control yeah and there's
only two things you can do in that
moment which is either i'm [ __ ]
or
it's okay and and how you support it's
okay
is with some kind of faith
i guess yeah i i because i've come to it
a long time ago that i have no control
over anything but i
i've been struggling with faith i'll
just throw myself into
religion sometimes but the problems with
that is
then you get into churches and stuff and
then you get into
men and stuff like that you know what i
mean and then you go
it's very easy to fall into the trap of
going like religion's bad i mean i mean
god's bad because
this [ __ ] priest [ __ ] a kid yes
[ __ ] you know what i mean why does
that make god bad right any [ __ ]
sense it just means the people that
represent him yeah yeah yeah
questionable so um you know so then if
you go to any church obviously it's led
by fallible men and you can't believe in
them so you got to kind of come
you know come to it yourself somehow
but i really i don't have the answer of
how you do that or anything where are
you at with it now
i don't know i the only thing i've ever
explored is christianity i you know and
that kind of i liked it yeah but it's
just extremely hard to
to keep believing it's really [ __ ]
hard yeah you know because uh it's the
hardest thing to believe and i think i'm
not deep enough i don't know if that's
true
i i think that you know just by nature
of the fact that you're a comedian in
that part of the way you understand
things is by cutting through [ __ ]
you know with jokes i mean especially
you i mean you cut through [ __ ] i
mean you know you call [ __ ] on just
about anything you know very concisely
and in a very funny way that when you're
sitting here trying to sort of like you
stay
uh in in a place of faith in the you
know the you know the sort of the jesus
thing and the you know the and whatever
you're choosing to hang that faith on
there's going to be part of you that
thinks like that's just [ __ ] there
is
[Music]
especially when it's specific like that
but then i don't want to be a [ __ ]
idiot that goes like you know sometimes
you meet people they're like i'm
spiritual you're like what they're like
i have my own thing yeah like you why
you work at burger king you figured out
a [ __ ] whole thing by yourself yeah
well they they've got their own thing
that enables them to work at burger king
without hanging themselves that's a
pretty powerful yeah i don't wanna i'm
not gonna certainly if i'm not gonna
accept christianity i'm not gonna accept
some [ __ ] 17 year old girl's [ __ ]
idea well maybe you should just get a
job at burger king
maybe the humility of that will
will shed a little light it's like
because it's exactly the same
feeling i think you probably had when uh
when you had to deal with the blind guy
that you know there's something you know
outside of you there's there's bigger
struggles that are had by many people
and they they seem to survive i've
actually thought about working with
blind people because because i look back
on that time
and it really it was the first time you
really look outside yourself it's pretty
incredible the things that you observe
even as a writer or anything i think it
would be incredibly important well i
think that's important for like a
spiritual thing too is to not think
about yourself first yeah i think most
spiritual people
ego you're exactly right yeah and but i
think a lot of people go that's the way
to find it is to look inside yourself
but i think you're right i think it's
not it's to look outside
it's to try to get past your ego yeah to
get that thing hammered down to to
almost nothing to where you you actually
think about the better of somebody else
over yourself yeah and that's right [ __ ]
i would never be able to do that right
well that's very contrary to like
there's this other whole movement now
the positive thinking people
yeah all you gotta do is throw that
switch man everything's okay
hey don't be negative
i [ __ ] can't deal with that [ __ ] but
you got but you can see in acting or in
comedy that that works i
know like the person that goes hey man
i'm cool everything's gonna be good then
it is yeah
yeah that's like it's it's horrendous
but is it really i mean just because
you're denying your flaws and you know
everything else i mean you can sort of
fake it till you make it or there's a
lot of slogans act as if whatever it is
but but still it's like you know they
say that eventually this will just kick
in in earnest
yeah until one day you're like it's not
kicking in yeah this is [ __ ] up and
you guys misled me and [ __ ] all of you
the truth is it's dark and horrible and
we die alone [ __ ] you guys yeah
the yeah the the
what is it called if what act a shift
act as if i guess i understand what that
means yeah sure but act as if yeah but
all these books and all these things
you know the bowel cancer hasn't read
the book
you know what i mean they don't read
anything they're [ __ ] cancer
yeah i i whenever someone like people
start talking about organs i [ __ ]
check out i mean i can handle a lot of
dark [ __ ] you know i can fulfill my head
with stuff but when people start saying
like i have kidney failure i'm like oh
god oh no no
that's why those [ __ ] the scariest
movies all this to me were the like the
cronenberg movies it was always the
insides yeah i was biological i was
thinking about the fly recently
like
where that moment was like he's climbing
up the wall and he's like pretty weird
huh yeah like oh god
and then when he breaks apart and
there's a giant fly inside of him can we
turn this around somehow to end this
it's thing my act when i do my act yeah
i never think of a [ __ ] ending yeah i
just trickle off just [ __ ] me too
just to unravel i guess this is uh
good you're done
you guys feel okay with what happened
here every week i go why didn't i think
of something